Oh folks I just had a little glitch
there with the with a connection I hope
I don't have any problems with with the
connection today okay anyways I'm doing
fine doing a little better with my back
and today we have an exciting day but a
little different kind of topic today I'm
gonna be dealing with autism and
homosexuality and what is interesting is
that I was about to do another celebrity
but someone put a comment and that kind
of took me off course yeah I Tesla and
so I'm gonna deal with a little bit of
different subject today but again I want
you to know that this is related to
extinction okay
and I came about as a little bit of fan
mail today I'm just gonna do one letter
okay and it's this fellow who put a
comment there and he's at the following
he says is the upped ISM epidemic right
a result of nearly two centuries of
artificial human selections for things
like industrialization gay is out ISM a
mutation selected by culture or society
since social engineering changes what
culture or society allows okay it's a
subject matter that I'm quite interested
in because I wrote a book here it is the
extinction of the Neanderthals how they
disappeared and I'm writing now why I
wrote already another book related to
the same subject matter and it's titled
why homosexuality is on the rise and I
haven't been
editing it for now two years and I'll
probably get it out this year but what
is the overall theory and the theory is
that we've been inbreeding for the last
200,000 years if we take that number as
a start of our specie which is again an
arbitrary number having to do more with
mitochondrial Eve the fact that they
calculated that abroad 200 thousand
years ago that's when our species
started and so we've been inbreeding for
200,000 years we did not breathe with
the nando Thals as the Max Planck
Institute geneticists tell us because
they had to have an extinction for the
gander Thals
I have a different theory in the book
but my point is we've been inbreeding
for 200,000 years and today we are
suffering the consequences of inbreeding
that happens to all species plants
included so if you in breathe in breathe
in breathe in breathe at some point you
know through thousands of years at some
point you're gonna have a problem why
because you're gonna have a sequence of
bottlenecks population bottlenecks
followed by founders effects bottlenecks
founders attacked found about 90 pounds
effects and what that does is streamline
the genetic code it prevents to have
genetic diversity and today we have no
genetic diversity very little okay and
here's a an example gay came out on
Oxford news about a few years ago says
that a group of chimps that they looked
at three groups of chimps yes near
Nigeria and there were maybe a hundred
chimps and these hundred chimps that
live in this clan or tribe have more
diversity between them than all of the
human race between the Chinese and
American are Russian in a South American
there's more diversity among this group
of chimps than all of humanity and he
say how can that possibly be and they
don't have an explanation
today for that okay and I say it's got
to do with the fact that we've been in
Breen for a long period of time and
there's more to it than that we've been
subjected to diseases and we conquered
those diseases because they're endemic
and because we are no longer conquering
new territory we are we have settled
down as a species we are sedentary okay
but that's a long story the issue here
is that because we lost our genetic
diversity this is my theory that's what
I'm proposing we're having these kinds
of problem we're having genetic diseases
and ailments we have increase in autism
conjoined twins we are having more of
those we have lower sperm count this has
been measured in the last 20 30 years
more general cavities and young children
these are just examples okay just pieces
there right we have over 200 enta fied
over 200 and mewn diseases okay and we
have smaller brains and we had in the
past so that apparently we went to a
peak and then started coming down these
are some of the things that are out
there yeah how much you how much weight
you should put on some of these claims
well it's up to everybody you know but I
think that we are suffering some
problems and one of those is
homosexuality I think it's part of this
process and here's an example
it's the Amish when the Amish came to
the United States about 500 years ago
they had maybe 1500 families and from
those 1,500 families you have 325
thousand people today that came mostly
from that group and so they've been
inbreeding over and over again for the
last 500 years and today they're
suffering genetic diseases and among
them you know what you see here they
have also homosexuals bisexuals and
transgendered
which I lump all under today I love them
all under homosexuals okay so I'm saying
all this is a consequence of the fact
that humans have lost their genetic
diversity I think that's the main
ingredient some people say well it's the
food weed it's the agricultural
corporations which are poisoning with
all this weed killers and whatever well
I put a little weight on that there
could be another factor that could be
cultural factors and one of those is
density which I'm gonna deal with today
but I think the primary one is we lost
our genetic code we have very little
diversity among the human race for the
number of people that we have and I
think that happens to all species
eventually they in breed after their
sedentary and they can't avoid going
extinct in what's called a background
extinction fortunately if in our case in
our case we're gonna die a lot swifter
in a mass extinction that's that's my
Gabi that's that is my are you I'm going
to talk about that today but what I'm
saying if we did not die in a mass
extinction we did not become extinct
through this mass extinction process
which is the overturning of the
ecological pyramid we would die we would
eventually whittle away slowly because
of this because of genetic loss of
genetic diversity and the overturning of
the population pyramid okay so those are
going to be my argument that's where I'm
gonna introduce homosexuality and autism
in the extinction to you okay that's
that's an ingredient I'm saying these
two are markers that Mother Nature is
showing us evidence clues that we are
the last humans on earth no matter what
okay okay
question here is how did I get involved
with a subject and I because I've been
researching this for 35 years since 1985
to be exact
why do I know this so well well I had a
little incident with with my wife we we
went
what is it a honeymoon trip to Miami and
from there into the Bahamas get some
Bahama Mama's and we had a great time
and on this love boat it was a Love Boat
Norwegian line we met a waiter and this
waiter befriended us and he he talked to
us at cetera and he asked us where we
were from we said well we came from
California when you live in Sunnyvale
and that's close to San Francisco oh I
always wanted to I was dreamed of being
in San Francisco living in San Francisco
okay and so I said well you know I gave
him my phone number and I said you know
if someday you're over there in
California give me a call and we're
gonna get a couple beers and it turns
out that as soon as he leaves my wife
who is he's a witch okay she's got like
the six at seven cents and she says you
know this guy's homosexual he's gay I
said well where did you get that how did
you come to that conclusion
she says this guy's gay and I said how
did you know that how did you figure
that out and she said well you know he's
got that little earring that was that's
around the time when it was earring
thing started and he was also carrying a
little purse which was also common at
the time was a fad but it's no longer
around as far as I know you know but men
were carrying the little person the
little thing and they they looked very
effeminate and she says he she said I
said well lots of people doing that I
mean a lot of guys are doing that in
fact maradona the our football player in
argentina he had the little ring he was
carrying the little wallet there in his
hand since its enormous and he said he
always dreamed of going in San Francisco
I said well that was context - I mean if
we would have said that we lived in New
York he said oh I always dreamed of
being in New York and I mean I don't
think so because nothing in his
appearance showed anything otherwise
three months later I receive a call from
San Francisco from a telephone public
phone and it's this fellow who had
JumpShip and he was in San Francisco and
he had no place to go
I said sure no problem I'll go and pick
you up so we went with my wife we picked
him up brought him our home and he
stayed with us like three or four weeks
around that time something happened also
in the news and asked that there was
this famous actor that a lot of young
people today may not know of his name
was Rock Hudson and he came out as gay
which was a big blow to a lot of women
because he was this macho guy in the
movies etc and he comes out as gay he
came out as homosexual because he had he
had AIDS he had contracted HIV and so he
had nothing to lose he had very short
time to live so he just came out and
told the world and we were sitting at
the table one day with this fellow his
name was Rosario just gonna give him his
first name Rosario which is turns out in
Spanish in Spanish it's a feminine name
yeah it's like st. Susanoo something
like that and he said he he told us he
was sorry for Rock Hudson and bla bla he
was and I wondered about the guys in
Rock Hudson why and then he said that he
was gay as well so my wife had been
right he was homosexual and so we had
this thing going on you know talked
about and he put us up to date on a lot
of stuff as far as homosexuality he said
his father beat the crap out of him
every day he had an older brother who
was according to him was look normal
like 2 years older than him and
sympathized with him but his father had
no sympathy and just beat him every day
now if his father what was not clear was
whether his father beat him up to make a
man out of him you know what I mean or
because he was gay so I'm gonna show you
you know that kind of thing so that
never came clear well it turns out that
I got him a job you know at Wendy's he
was flipping burgers got him some
documents I did all that stuff and he
was working but then I you know we
started wandering with my wife you know
oh this guy's gay and we have this AIDS
thing going around you know so I was a
little worried about that I have a 7
year old kid here in in my house you
know
and one night my wife wakes up goes to
the kitchen to get a drink of water and
she says come create comfort and I said
what the hell happened here I go to the
kitchen and we're both in the dark
looking outside the window and there's a
car parked in front of our house and the
passenger opens the door and it's this
fellow Rosario and he's talking with a
fellow who drove them a little bit last
words and then he gives him a kiss in
the mouth and I'll spare you the details
of that and were the first time in my
life I had us seen a man kiss another
man
I had gone to Castro and market in San
Francisco several times to take tourists
who came to visit us at her house they
wanted to say hey I would see the Freak
Show over there in San Francisco so we
would drive around the Castro shown you
know the gay bars and all the hundreds
of gays on the streets holding hands or
walking one time I saw only once I saw
two lesbians kissing themselves exactly
at the corner of market and Castro there
and but never to guys and this was the
first time I saw two guys well worried
about the AIDS issue with San Francisco
only a few miles away with a lots of
homosexuals there and good ol Rock
Hudson contracting aids suddenly you
know this this issue popped like in my
face and I had to tell this guy to leave
I was worried that he was going to drink
from a glass and that my kid was just
gonna grab the glass and maybe pick up
you know HIV because we didn't know much
about it at the time
remember HIV came in 81 82 that's when
it came out in the news I found out
later that it was already since the
1920s known in Africa but it didn't come
Wes and it didn't get into the news up
till 81 82 and here we were in 1985
three years later and this thing had
grown especially among the population of
San Franciscans in fact they called it
Gades which didn't set well with me and
my job because they would say that many
times the the other engineers would just
joke around with me say hey gates yeah
and so yeah I was worried about my son
getting infected and so I told him to
leave and I never saw him again
but as a result I went to the library
and got myself three books on the
subject I don't remember the third book
the second book was a book by
psychologists and psychiatrists telling
their cases think case histories I went
they handled themselves and a third book
was the ones that impact me quite a bit
this guy was saying the author was
saying that just about everyone in the
past every important figure Alexander
the great Julius Caesar Marcus and Mark
Anthony all the way to Frederick the
Great you know everyone had been gay
that's is this possible but were they
gay I mean this was a new world that
opened up to me as far as I knew until
then homosexuality never existed except
maybe in San Francisco this was a gay
capital of the world
other than that I had very little
understanding or no understanding really
Oh of this homosexual world and so I
started researching that and from that
point on so I know for a fact that for
35 years I've been investigating this
subject now this came up to the fore
when I started looking at around 1998 I
started looking at extinction the
extinction of man and at first I
identified it with this trend of
homosexuality and out ISM that was
growing I said oh hold it this stuff's
he's growing maybe that's gonna kill us
okay later on I rejected that for man I
said no man is gonna die something else
you can't die in a mass extinction but
these are clues these are markers that
Mother Nature sprinkles to make us aware
that something is wrong with our species
we're at the end of the line one way or
the other okay and so I found out later
while I was doing my research on
extinction about this something I put in
in the book which here I'm putting it
for the first time okay
and so this is out of the book that I'm
writing or I wrote and
says in 1973 the American psychiatry
Association Declassified homosexuality
is a mental disorder alleging among its
reasons changing social norms and
growing gay rights activism in other
words this milestone was a political
rather than a scientific decision okay
and what I was showing is that there was
a growing population of homosexuals and
that's why they suddenly gained the
power to do this okay it was the result
of militant gay and Pro gay activists
and psychiatrists such as Charles
silverstein and Georg Weinberg if ever
there was a small minority which brought
forces to bear at the right place at the
right time to overturn the wishes and
attitudes of the overwhelming majority
of people and win a vital strategic
secret war it was in the fight to get
homosexuality off the list of disorders
two years later the American
Psychological Association followed suit
essentially the shrinks reason that
there is no scientific evidence that
homosexuality is a mental disorder
therefore there was no basis to include
it in the list to begin with right
so 1973 these guys declared it they
pulled it out of the category of
disorders interesting in the enough they
did not remove transsexualism and other
bisexual and others they didn't remove
the only removed homosexuality that that
is important to note but anyways who are
these guys
and that that had so much power well
they were people who snuck up behind a
Christian right well the Christian Right
was you know putting all these
charismatic people like pat robertson
and Oral Roberts to get you know people
to give them donation so they could fly
around in their jets
these psychology spheres I got a handful
of people they went out there and they
said no we know what we got to do we got
to remove homosexuality from the list of
disorders and that's gonna be the key
milestone and these are the two fellows
I think the guy on the left is dead now
around and he's the guy who coined the
term homophobia okay the guy Orion he's
a psychologist he made the presentation
before the psychiatrist to get them to
lead to the beat okay homosexuality from
the list of disorders and so why is this
important well it's important because is
homosexuality a disorder is it normal
and for this if we're gonna treat it
objectively without any emotion we have
to define the word normal scientifically
because that's essentially what we're
going to do and you can replace that
with any other synonym or something
similar no problem I use the word normal
is homosexuality normal and so I give
this notion so that you can figure out
you know where I'm coming from on the
issue of normality what does normal mean
and I'm saying let's assume you you go
to the pond and you see the ducks there
you see the swans and suddenly you see a
Black Swan if so uh black someone I
thought all swans were white not because
the race is a red it's it's the color of
swans right normally you see I thought
all those swans were white here's a
Black Swan well it turns out you do a
census of all the swans on earth and you
find out that two percent of them are
black so there's a small minority but
it's normal for there to be a black swan
so if you come across the Black Swan
well that's normal because two percent
of them are black okay so now you do
something else you do a census in 1960
1970 1980 2000 and it's always 2% 2% 2%
now you reach 2010 you do a census and
there's 5% and you do another census in
2020 and it's 10%
so now you say Oh hold it something's
going on here this is no longer normal
because something is changing we need to
investigate what's going on maybe it's
cosmetic because maybe it's just the
color of the feathers maybe it says the
you know the Black Swan had more kids or
whatever you know so but it's something
you want to investigate and you say this
is not normal because it's not what
you've seen in the past two percent well
the same applies to gays and homosexuals
you know if their numbers are increasing
and you do a census and over time you
see that that number is increasing as a
percentage of the population that's no
longer cosmetic if that's happening okay
and so I think it's important to
understand or to figure out to determine
whether this homosexuality thing is
expanding it's getting more and more
people and by almost sexuality I'm
including all of them ok I'm again
transsexual bisects the whole sexual
gamut okay so the the issue here is
whether the percentage of homosexuals
are increasing and so one of the ways
you do this is by statistics yeah you do
polls and statistics these are some of
the numbers I pulled out of the
Wikipedia out of several polls that have
been out there and you can see that from
2000 which worth I think around 2002 for
one of these countries another one was
like 2006 so I just put the round number
2000 and then in the 2010s 2015 16 s all
the way to 2018 you see that the numbers
have increased okay of the numbers of in
this case the first one UK is the number
of it's a decrease in heterosexuals and
the Canadian Australia the number of
increases in homosexuals okay so the UK
is a little different than the others
but they all show a trend of an increase
in homosexuality and right underneath
there you see Germany for one year I
can't remember the year now they just
did a poll and they showed that 63
percent of people identified as
straight and about 24% is gay and then
13 decided not to respond or we're
undecided or whatever and within the 18
to 24 bracket the numbers were higher
meaning that the new generation
apparently has more homosexuals among
them the Z generation okay generation Z
Brazil 10 cities 16.7% u.s. 6.9 you can
see there's a very big difference in
some of these numbers from one country
to another and so yeah the issue comes
up whether you should put the hand your
hand in the fire for polls and for
statistics it's just one data point okay
that's all it's another thing to keep in
mind that you see that none of them show
a decrease they all show an increase it
could be a sampling bias you know maybe
in the past we didn't take this good
care of finding out all these things and
that's also has to be considered okay
but if you put it in together what I
looked at which is the fact that
homosexuals flooded the psychiatrist's
office in the 60s and 70s they said hey
I got a problem doc you gotta cure me
and what was the doctor gonna do here
take the red pill a potion to cure
homosexuality we got put the electrodes
and change you even if the homo-sex who
wants to change his orientation assuming
that right what are you gonna do put the
electrodes there was no cure for this
and again as far as I'm concerned
because it's a genetic thing I agree
with them you're born that way and
that's one of the things this fellow a
Rosario told me he said that he was born
with it and I never had a problem with
that I said I really think these people
are born like that and it's got nothing
to do with the food and the environment
maybe education helps in some way
efficacy what I'm going to talk about in
a minute density population density
especially in the cities the rat race
yeah that might affect as well might
have an influence there there are many
variables to to ponder here okay but I
think the main one is genetics ok and ok
so moving on here one another way of the
termini how if the numbers have
increased is to look at history you know
it's a common knowledge out there
popular knowledge that you know all the
Greeks were gay and all the Romans were
gay right everyone is a persons of
Chinese all these people in the old days
they were all gay they had no problem
with homosexuality and the question is
whether that's true I mean people just
repeat what they hear and then without
doing your research yeah they were all
gay it looks like all these guys agree
but you got to remember the people who
doing research on homosexuality are
homosexuals they're they're concerned
they want to know why they are like they
are and so there are the people doing
research on homo-sex well we don't have
too many people like me who are not into
that world but research it anyways okay
and so this is part of the problem more
news comes from the homosexual world
about homosexuality then it comes from
what you call the straight world okay
and so I started looking at the history
and finding out well is it true that you
know in the past there were homosexuals
were all these people like Alexander and
the Caesar and so on homosexuals and I
started looking at some of these cases
in the past started researching one case
at a time and again I've been at it for
over 20 years
okay and this one that the guys you want
to start with if you do a little
research he's essentially the guy who
made popular the notion among the
university's intellectual classes you
could say the issue that all Greeks were
homosexual I'm being I'm exaggerating
but essentially he introduced the fact
that oh you know the Greeks hey they had
it in their culture it was widespread
and so he does an analysis of what he
analyzes base paintings you know the the
paintings on the basis that the Greeks
made as Kinney's court case very
important against tamarcus and in that
case fortunate survived to today and if
you look at it the it's a long case if I
did the whole thing is there the whole
transcript but practic
and in fact I think it's in its totality
and essentially you know what happens in
against tamarcus is that the entire
Athenian code against homosexuality is
essentially spelled out yeah the guy
analyzes everything because he wants to
port to Marcus on a business and in fact
they took the citizenship away from
Jamarcus who was the prosecutor who was
gonna prosecute skinny's okay so because
he was one of the people who visited the
Court of Philip of Macedon and they say
he was bribed so they were gonna put him
in jail I guess they could execute him
and so he turned this case around and
brings it against DeMarcus saying he has
no right to sue me because he's
homosexual that's what against DeMarcus
is about so you should read it if you're
interested in that type of subject
Aristophanes comedy's and he also looked
at literary and philosophical Texans old
what are his conclusions well
essentially this is just overall race
regarded homosexuality in general to be
a natural normal and salutary to be net
and their actual practices were
circumscribed by a cultural norms and
then he also emphasizes pederasty and
international intergenerational sexual
relations between two males that's the
essentially the definition okay and he
says it was widespread among the Greece
so and of course it's a more involved
book but he goes through all this it's
important to note one thing which I did
a research he says that out of thousands
of vases Greek vases he found like a tea
that had homosexual images and when you
look at those images I looked up a lot I
didn't look at all a tea that you
mentioned but I looked at a lot of them
I even went to the Lubar and to the what
is it
a museum in Britain with the British
Museum and other museums as well and I
found a lot of these vases and when you
look at them yeah
you'll find one thing and a lot I'd say
at least 50% of the motives here it's
just one motive and it's Zeus and
Ganymede and just briefly Ganymede was
the son of priam prime was the king of
Troy okay one uh one of the sons the
other two were Paris and actor you know
that I've got a fight against Achilles
and it turns out that Zeus comes in as
an eagle dressed as an ego or whatever
sends an eagle right and picks up
Ganymede
takes him to heaven takes him to heaven
to be the cup bearer of the gods okay
and then they took him out there because
apparently the kid was cute handsome and
Hera his wife his sister also I was
always jealous of him and so they always
insinuate that existed a little more
that with Ganymede than just have him as
a cup bearer and that's what the motive
is it you know these you know what the
topic is in all these vases lots of
half-owner you look at them closely
you'll find out it's Zeus and Ganymede
yay
and just as a note Ganymede
Romans they call Khatami tus okay that's
gonna be to something green well I might
raise that later on okay anyways this is
the guy to start with guy kenneth Dover
and here's a one fella who because what
they try to say is look we have all this
evidence from the Greek literature and
famous one is Achilles Achilles and
Patroclus and supposedly they were
lovers and when you go to see Alexander
and have fest Gian his right-hand man in
the war against the Persians they say
that in fact uh I think that's what the
record shows that Alexander thought hims
saw of himself as Achilles and that's
how he regarded himself you know he
always thought himself as Achilles
invincible in battle here he Achilles
was his his hero and he had the right
partner like Patroclus which was half
stn so they always associate these two
called couples yeah and here's one guy
who just one example there's a lot of
people write this okay I'm just pulling
one example this is a writer he writes
Alexander the Great and he says it was
remarkable tribute uniquely paid and is
also half st ins first mentioned in
Alexander's career already the two were
intimate okay but proc loose and
Achilles even to those around them
that's that's what chef Estie --n and
Alexander were they were the Achilles
and Patroclus yeah and the comparison
would remain to the end of their days
and his proof of their life as lovers
okay for by Alexander Stein Achilles and
Patroclus were agreed to have enjoyed a
relationship which Homer himself had
never directly mentioned so where did he
get this that Achilles and Patroclus had
sexual relations if Homer never
mentioned where else is he getting his
information okay and here well leave
this up there and here let me show you
no I better take it out here we have
testimony from Plato himself yay I mean
if you don't believe Homer well here you
have Plato but where does Plato get
information yet sir from Homer from the
Iliad
right very different was the reward of
the true love of Achilles towards his
lover Patroclus his lover and not his
love the notion that Patroclus was the
beloved one is a foolish hair into which
Aeschylus has fallen and for Achilles
was surely the fair of the two fair also
than all other heroes and as Homer
informs us he was still beardless no
beard okay so apparently he is saying
that Achilles was younger he was
beardless he was too youthful to be the
peddler ass he was the guy on the bottom
right okay and younger by far okay
and still and greatly as the gods honor
the virtue of love still the return of
love on the part of the beloved to the
lover is more admired and valued and
rewarded by them for the lovers more
divine because he is inspired by God
okay so this is the
testimony of mr. Plato and the question
is whether he's even in the ballpark did
you ever read Homer and let me tell you
why I have a little doubts about mr.
Plato having read Homer and here's the
evidence
yo you want evidence you will put the
evidence and here's from The Iliad
itself okay and it says Achilles slept
in an inner room this is chapter nine
and beside him the daughter of forbus
lovely diameter whom he had carried off
from lesbos the practice lay on the
other side of the room and with him fair
IFAs whom Achilles had given him when he
took Cyrus the city of onions okay so
here you have two so-called homosexuals
and they are visited by two beautiful
girls and instead of you know sleeping
together and having the two girls just
stay there twiddling their thumbs no
each one chose one of the girls they
slept in different rooms with the girls
now how many times has that happened in
San Francisco among gays you know when
two girls come and visit them and they
say well Johnny I think I'm gonna sleep
with this girl not with you today I
don't think so
so where does he get this idea that
Achilles and Patroclus we're homosexuals
menhir you have almost evidence I mean
you need the camera or what to go in
there and see them sleeping with the
girls okay and here's another clue and
again I don't know how good ole Plato
missed and I wonder if you ever read the
Homer you know the Iliad and here you
see it this is the start of OB Ilya this
is uh the first chapter yeah what does
it say what's what how does it start
Agamemnon fighting Achilles arguing
bitterly because the pria priest comes
over okay wants to take his daughter
away which was taken as a prize for
Agamemnon crisis and so they say look
I'm gonna pay you some ransom but I need
my girl back the priest says to like I'm
at now so
and the god he consults the gods that
God say yeah you better let him go
because he's a priest of Apollo and you
gotta let this girl go and so he lets
her go and he's got no no prize
everybody everybody had all the generals
have prizes except him and he's the
commander of the army and so he'd send
an argument there with Achilles until he
said well you know in the next battle
we'll get you a girl and don't worry
about it and so I got on what does he do
he says oh no I'm gonna take your girl
and he takes prices away from Achilles
and so now now Achilles is upset and he
goes off he says I'm not gonna go to war
I'm not gonna fight and he just says you
know I'm not gonna take this it's an
insult to me and he doesn't come back
into the war until his buddy
Patroclus is killed okay then he wants
vengeance now against Hector who killed
his buddy right but the fight is over a
girl I mean how many times does that
happened two homosexuals in San
Francisco I mean you know I have a lot
of doubts about some of these people who
just say things and they don't even
research the basics the book
iliyan is there a field for anyone to
look at look at chapter 9 you'll see it
somewhere near the center you'll see
that these two guys are sleeping with
women and at the beginning of Iliad
tells you that Achilles was not
homosexual Pesce because he already left
a wife in murdered on Mildenhall where
where he was from okay
he already left the wet behind marathon
that's what it was okay but some of
these people insist they do again
homosexuals do research on all this
stuff
not heterosexuals as a problem because
it's lopsided okay they introduced their
opinions as fact okay and here's one guy
and he's homosexual as you can see
that's his partner they're both dead
right now but they were a couple for
until he died
John Boswell died of AIDS okay he's at
Yale professor so he's an influential
person okay if there was a law against
homosexual relations in
none in cicero's they knew anything
about it here we're talking about Rome
now we just covered Greece another we
have a couple errors there for sure now
here we got Rome and says that nobody
knew that there was a law against
homosexuality this guy doesn't know well
I'm sure he knew about it he just
interpreted in his own way or he dismiss
it like saying well it wasn't enforced
that's essentially I think he's his
argument and why do I have a problem
with that babe because here you have
another statement from this guy and he
says a semi beer which is a semi man or
homosexual fears the Lexx continue on
and elects let's scan tinea was the law
against homosexuals in Rome so I'm sure
this fellow uh possible he knew about it
right he just dismissed it like saying
well nobody enforced it meaning that hey
everybody can go around the town
screwing anybody who wants sleeping with
anyone he wished because nobody
everybody disregarded the law the
so-called Lux Cantina which was a law
against homosexual and here we have
another testimony again from a pair of
homosexuals yeah and this is what they
say they say clearly an assumption among
Romans was that as a group men normally
experience desire for both male and
female and male is that so
oh my god I gotta check myself male
bodies and at any given and that any
given man might act out those desires
with persons of one or the other sex or
both well obviously it's a homosexual
who's talking okay maybe he's bisexual
maybe he has his experience he can't
speak for Humanity but he's already
putting all these words in in the mouths
of the Romans yeah it's like I think
you're reading too much into history
buddy
and here's another lesbian and she's a
teacher as well a professor at UCLA
it was expected and socially acceptable
for a Freeborn Roman man to one sex with
male partners young men were considered
normal objects of desire you know this
is kind of weird because if this is true
something happened because if everybody
was homosexual in the days of Roman
Greece and today you go to Greece and
Rome and Roman you know Italy they're
all most of them people are heterosexual
how do you make that transition from
homosexual or bisexual to heterosexual
you know if we went from gay to straight
I don't know they would have to explain
that
metamorphosis okay so what do I have a
problem with this with fishy with this
lady down there well here it is here's a
paper that analyzes one of her writings
and says despite such condemnation
something akin to a homosexual
subculture subcultura underline that did
develop at Rome as both Amy Richland and
Robin Taylor have persuasively argued no
fewer than three texts refer to
scratching one's head with a single
finger as a semiotic gesture between
homosexual men that such coded signals
evolve during the late Republic suggest
strongly the presence of an underground
network with its own conventions and
rules even as wearing a red tie or
adopting certain affectations of speech
would make homosexuals recognizable to
one another in the early 20th century
well the question is why did they have
to have a subculture or an underground
network in Rome if as all these people
argue it was normal for homosexual for
men to be attracted to men and to have
sex among men something has to be
explained and these people around
explain they're just making statements
based on their own preconceived notions
based on their own biases right about
what the Romans did 200 2000 years ago
and yeah I have a little bit of
skepticism
to say the least basically when you see
these other testimonies of people saying
that the homosexual had to go
underground they could do it in the open
for sure and so we have a condom and we
have the lux canteen yeah which this guy
says homosexual fare safir's the Lexx
cantina and what the homosexuals do they
brush it under the rug and they say well
I never happened because nobody cared
about it you know we don't know how many
people were prosecuted for let's scan
tinea for being homosexual yeah and so
to read something mm you know to
something that's 2,000 years old with
the minds that we have here I think is
part of the problem can we we can't put
our minds completely into what people in
the old days did all we can do is try to
read their writings object as
objectively as possible and not try to
judge so quickly and again I find a lot
of contradictions between what the gay
lobby these people are lobbyists what
the gay lobby is spreading out there and
what you actually see in the original
records of sources right okay another
famous fellow for being gay and also a
monster was and for those who read a
little bit of history no well his name
was Nero okay and so this is something
it comes out of to a couple of the books
when his tacit is he said Nero himself
defiled by every natural and unnatural
lust had left no abomination and
reserved with which to crown his vicious
existence except that a few days later
he spores okay I'll talk about in a
second became the full the full rights
of legitimate marriage the wife of one
of the heard one of that herd of
degenerates who bore the name Pythagoras
and here we see a little more about that
issue
besides abusing Freeborn boys and
seducing married women okay so obviously
he did he apparently was bisexual right
not homosexual he bucks the vestal
virgin rubra meaning he liked women
obviously right and the freed woman
acted he all but made his lawful wife
after bribing some ex-con
to perjure themselves by swearing that
she was of royal birth he castrated the
Boise poorest and actually tried to make
a woman of him and he married him with
all the usual ceremonies including a
dowry and a bridal veil took him to his
home attended by a great throng and
treated him as his wife now how's that
for homosexuality is that uh not only
depraved and nuts he burned Rome Ryan
but obviously he was a monster in fact
he was accused of kicking his wife in
the stomach when she was pregnant he
killing both the baby and her and then
he killed his mother so this guy was a
monster okay narrow and just in case
here's another testimony important I'm
not gonna read it completely I'll read
the second part here only because a
little different than the others now
Nero called spora Sabina not merely
because owing to his resemblance to her
he had been made a eunuch but because
the boy like the mistress had been
sullenly married to him in Greece as the
Lord and all the Greeks held a
celebration in honor of their marriage
uttering all the customary good wishes
even to the extent of praying that
legitimate legitimate children might be
born to them okay and so that's
interesting I don't know how to
homosexuals we'll have kids right but
after that Nero had to bed fellows at
once pythagoras to play the role of
husband to him and spores that of wife
the latter in addition to other forms of
address was turned lady Queen and
mistress yet why should one wonder at
this scene that Nero would fasten naked
boys and girls to stakes and then
putting on the hide of a wild beast
would attack them and satisfy his brutal
lust under the appearance of devouring
parts of their bodies such were the
indecencies of Nero man scary guy did
this ever happen
and yeah Nero has a bad name out there
okay now let me tell you something about
Nero here if I can find him here
and it comes from these scene thing sing
fellows Tacitus spittoon use and cashews
dial and so let's put them in the right
context to see if any of this has any
validity yeah about Nero poor Nero Nero
was the last of the Giulio Claudian
dynasty that started with Augustus okay
so starting without Gus this all the way
to Nero who was the last guy of that
dynasty you know this was the Giulio
Claudian dynasty Tacitus was born twelve
years before nero died he was only 12
years old Niro died did he go to the De
Niro's chamber and see the three
together the three guys in bed together
Suetonius he's a historian he was born
one year after Nero died and Cassius
died oh he was born 100 years after Nero
died the dynasty that replaced Nero
because there was what is called a year
of the Four Emperors there were four
guys killing each other okay until the
guy who prevailed was vest patient and
he started the Flavian dynasty okay and
because of that one of the issues was
that they had to destroy the name of the
to do Claudian dynasty they had to throw
dirt on him and the best way to throw
dirt on someone was to say that he was
homosexual it was not glorified it was
it's like Cicero - Marc Anthony he Marc
Anthony he calls him a cat amitis at one
point he refers to me is that cat a
mantis and Kitana this was the word for
there was the Roman word for Ganymede
and that was considered a bottom
considered a guy who received it okay
and so that was the worst thing you
could say to a man that he was a catana
test and he that's how he treated Marc
Marc Anthony of course Marc Anthony came
back and eventually had him killed
cats kill so that's fight among the
Giants up there you know in the upper
world but
no the these guys have to throw dirt on
the guy before him and dynasty in fact
that all of them because if you look at
the entire dynasty of the of Augustus to
to Nero oh maybe these these people were
the worst people on earth they were
promiscuous they were homosexual they
were bisexual they had although
disgraces that you can imagine why
because they had to throw dirt under
name
partly because Nero was not that
unpopular he was quite popular with the
troops still and that's a lot of story
to tell you all this but yeah if you
read out there you find out that Nero is
not such a monster as they paint him out
to be but the Flavian dynasty had to
throw dirt on him okay and you say well
bill that's your interpretation yeah it
could be but here let me give you proof
and evidence and and something to ponder
about okay here it is and this comes
from the same old passages in fact it's
the first line in his book the annals
and he says the the annals the histories
of Tiberius chaos
Claudius an arrow while they were in
power were falsified through terror and
after their death were written under the
irritation of a recent hatred and we
read in a Wikipedia another common
similar to that ancient sources alleged
poverty for the Flavian family at the
time of the missions upbringing even
claiming Vespasian had fallen into
disrepute under the Emperor's Caligula
and Nero modern history has refuted
these claims suggesting these stories
were later circulated under Flavian rule
as part of a propaganda campaign to
diminish success under less reputable
Emperors of the Giulio Claudian dynasty
and maximize achievements under Emperor
Claudius and his son Britannicus okay so
the victors to the victors goes the
prize victors write history so you got
to be very careful what you read and
whether you accept the fishy history
everything verbatim loser
if you're going to put the hint your
hand in the fire for all this stuff yeah
be careful and here's a final example
also from Rome few years later and here
you have this fellow and I also put in
my book after Carrick alia was
assassinated his aunt juley young Meza
maneuvered to eliminate his successor
and likely murder Macrinus and placed
her grandson elect gapless on the throne
the problem was that Julie and her
influential sisters and daughters as
well as Elagabalus were from Syria they
were off from the east they brought a
little bit of different culture to Rome
bestial Agha bolus he was the high
priest of Allah gobble and oriental Sun
God and apparently tried to impose his
religion upon the Romans specially on
the senate under rich people it is said
that Elagabalus wore colorful and fancy
oriental tonics and probably used
cosmetics and makeup which was quite
popular among the well-to-do in the
region from Egypt to Syria his personal
appearance as well as his attempt to
replace the traditional gods of Rome
must have culturally shocked and
threatened the ruling classes when his
grandmother realized that she couldn't
control him she maneuvered once more
behind the scenes and had him removed
and replaced by another of her grandsons
she hadn't killed essentially Severus
Alexander he was eventually murdered as
well thus ending the severan severan
dynasty it was quite customary in those
days for the new emperor to ask the
Senate to condemn the previous ruler
under the label then natio memory and we
raised his name and many other times his
wife as well entirely from the public
record this is what his successor did to
Elega bollocks
they not only erased his name and deeds
but to ruin his name completely
popularize the story that he was almost
a homosexual okay so there's a lot of
politics and all these things in fact it
happened to lots of people had happened
to Alexander you know when he was
murdered I'm sure he was murdered that's
my opinion
you know the diet okay which were his
generals they fought forward the Empire
they split it up fishy and Tipler he was
in Greece and his son Cassandra
they eventually murdered Alexander's
mother his wife Roxanne and their son
Alexander the six because he was the
rightful king right
so they murdered them in the ER so
murdering a half-brother that Alexander
had they murdered the MA and antipathy
and Cassander his son later inherited
what the region run Greece that was
their empire Ptolemy you know inherited
Egypt then from there you have Leo Petra
many years later she was from the
Ptolemy Ptolemy line okay so what can we
conclude from all this are all these
heroes of all these great men of
politics were they homosexual well let
me give you some more evidence here here
we have Alexander the Great yeah he had
at least two wives Rosana and Stata and
he had a son Alexander the fourth sorry
I thought it was the six aiexander the
fourth who was later killed by a tippler
or Cassander I think it was his son that
killed Julius Caesar was married to
Cornelia pompeia and California and have
a child cesarean who was murdered by
Augustus right when when he or Petra
committed suicide or was suicided what
other dude with Cleopatra so he had a
son with their Patra then Mark Antony
also sleeps with her so and Mark Anthony
was accused by a sister of being
contaminoids it turns out that he slept
with Cleopatra so all these homosexuals
Jemez they lusted after women for some
reason beautiful women right in those
days for them right so it makes you
wonder
Nero he was married to Octavia Sabina
and Messalina and got sabina pregnant
twice this doesn't sound like
homosexuals you know and and so it makes
you wonder what the homosexual lobby
whether they're telling the truth or
they're just giving you their personal
opinions as fact yeah I think there's a
lot going on and you know your interest
you got to do a lot of research you know
and find out that
there's a lot of cases that show quite
the contrary that these guys were not
homosexuals but they're tweeters
homosexuals by the homosexual lobby
because they need to have some heroes
because there is no mention of
homosexuality in in history except in a
negative light
that's all you see okay I mean Leviticus
you know put them to death I know I'll
get to that in a second here anyways
that's the next topic see if I can find
it here it's way down at the bottom
when did homosexuality start I mean were
there homosexuals in in the old days or
not am I saying that there weren't and
so I have to trace that issue I mean how
do you go about doing this so you try to
figure out if there were homosexual in
the past you look in the record to find
out what clue you can find there and you
know that might give you an idea that
yeah there were homosexuals in the past
maybe not the way the homosexual lobby
presents some of these people but I have
to believe that there were homosexuals
and let me tell you why and here's a
here's a clue okay and I also put that
in my book for you to take into
consideration the earliest laws the
codes of Birnam mu X nuna and lipid
Ishtar contain many provisions for
natural male female sexual relations not
one mentions homosexuals and a most
complete extant Constitution the Code of
Hammurabi contains 282 laws of which
about 1/3 govern the relations between
husband and wife females slaves
concubines and the man's sons now single
law in the Hammurabi code addresses
homosexuality so we're talking about
about 1800 to 2000 BC no one mentioned
homosexuality that's the point that I'm
trying to make here yeah there we have
to concede that homosexuality did not
exist was not widespread it was not a
problem or is not frowned upon by the
Akkadians
the Sumerians and Babylonians to it so
that's you can reach your own conclusion
from that all I'm saying is objectively
no one mentions in the codes in the
Constitution's of those states
no one mentions homosexuality in their
codes and you have tried to figure out
why and here's the first code that
mentions it in the history in our in our
history and that we know in other words
there could be codes out there we
haven't found yet okay but the first
code is this code is the code of Asura
okay
first extant Constitution in history to
mention homosexuality is the code of
Asura promulgated by a Syrian King
tiglath-pileser yeah the clauses aren't
and that's the 1100 BC yeah
approximately the clauses are not
included to lauder to encourage
homosexuality but to punish it severely
again never treated in in kind like by
our ancestors there you know Houma says
who were always treated in the worst
possible way because they were
considered as far as I'm concerned the
worst possible kind of human beings and
in article 18 if a man secretly says of
his companion one may have unnatural
intercourse and they were being kind
here with a translation intercourse with
him or in a brawl in the presence of men
says to him what has the had unnatural
intercourse with thee I will prove it
against thee but but it's not able to
prove it nor has proved it this man
shall receive fifty lashes do the king's
work for one month be mutilated i guess
he was castrated and pay one talent of
lead and article 19 if a man has had
unnatural intercourse with his companion
if it has been proved and a certain of
him that he has had unnatural
intercourse with him he shall be
castrated okay and so what does the gay
lobby have to say about this well you
know the gay lobbies are aware of a lot
of these things and they're worried
about that so they had to reinterpret
all all of these cases all of them
perfecting they had to end other choice
and here's one from this fellow he's
homosexual as well and he said he puts
us up to date on his opinion now he
interprets that code and he said this
describes a situation where a man has
forced forced sex upon a local resident
or business partner sounds like you're
mm reading 2,000 years ago interpreting
who then has the option of bringing a
charge against them in a court of law
of course right noticeably the
perpetrator is punished while the victim
is not so the prime here was here is
rape and it's interesting because always
the bottom gate lobby says it's always
the bottom and everything at the top is
the guy in the top right he's not the
guy that's - so he's the guy in the
bottom and here they're saying exactly
the opposite it's the top that's gonna
be punished and so he's got to interpret
that somehow you got to twist it around
say well let me interpret it for you
again Oh is he value itself is not
condemned oh it wasn't as long as it was
consent it was all okay that's his
argument nor looked upon is immoral or
disordered anyone could visit a
prostitute or lay with another male
anyone uh-huh as long as false rumors
are for sex for sex and for strober were
not involved with another assyrian male
so he's thinking saying that this is an
issue of force and consent which is
totally a twenty first twenty and twenty
first century issue these people didn't
know anything about consent and I had
never even wondered about consent
entering the picture in anything the way
I look at it in if in the old days a
guy's like a Petrov slept with a kid
forcefully they might execute him right
or whatever but if if the kids if they
asked a kid
the unfortunate no no it was consensual
I agree I think they would kill the kid
as well that's the way they didn't like
homosexuals had nothing to do with
consent and and today this issue consent
comes around you know they do concern
you know or did you have the age to
consent I think it played no role in the
old days at least that's my take on that
and still so still both of these laws
suggest that for a male to take a
submissive woman's role in same-sex
intercourse was looked down upon as
shameful and despised yeah he adds that
again he throws all covers all the bases
to to make sure that his interpretation
is right I think we just got to go
objectively by the record and say look
it's very clear here
if you and the first code just says if
you insult someone instead of saying you
know you sob that was not hard enough
but if you question his masculinity by
saying that he was homosexual whether
top or bottom and you could not prove it
they would castrate you you you you
offended the guy beyond any reasonable
doubt and if you did actually sleep with
another guy again whether you were top
or bottom
you were both executed period that's it
or castrated or whatever and Leviticus
shows the same thing you know all these
codes sell you the same thing you go to
the code of the Kyrgyz for the Spartans
same thing punished no no sex among men
on and on the Book of the Dead of the
Egyptians same thing it says you know
you had to recite a series of questions
not yeah question they were like
questions or you had to swear an oath to
those issues saying that and one of
those says I think number 20 says you
never slept with a with a man you have
to and so the the translations on that
little paragraph you wouldn't believe
all the translations that have been done
on that single line you know one-liner
because if you had to swear that you
never had slept with a man you know that
outlaws homosexuality and you know
obviously the homosexuals are gonna
reinterpret that whenever they can okay
and yeah you get no cases like this that
homosexuals are trying to change the
record retro actively some of you may
have heard of the Queen James Bible and
that's a gay B Bible and what they've
done is change all the clobber passages
all the passes there's at least eight of
them in the Bible I think there's a
couple more really but whatever the
point is they change these parodies
these paragraphs are these parts because
they talk badly about homosexuals and
they say hey I'm Christian you gotta
accept me and the Bible says no
and so what are you gonna do what are
you gonna tell so they had to change the
Bible - I guess the console the
homosexual lobby and here's just one
case of how they how they changed us
they say thou shalt not lie with mankind
as with womankind and he added in the
temple of moment it is an abomination in
other words they changed that little
piece there by adding that that segment
there that does not occur in the
original Bible they just changed it
because obviously the Bible says it very
clearly you know Leviticus which was
written of a on paper about five hundred
six hundred years ago before Christ but
it was passed on by oral tradition
before then and so these laws existed in
the in the books or in the minds of our
inner tribes or whatever in the villages
for a long period of time until they
decided to write them and the written
word is always against homosexuals
there's nothing positive ever written
about homosexuality yeah it's always in
the negative or most of it at least I
don't know maybe there's someplace for
someone in fact I did find some places
again I think like people like Plato I
think he must have been homosexuals he
talks a lot about that yeah okay so
where does this take us well it takes us
to these days and it's got to do with
the fact that they're the numbers of
homosexuals has increased again I'm
saying they increase not because the
statistics say so
but because they swapped up with
psychiatrists offices and they said do
something for me doc I'm homosexual
oh you're homosexual yeah what can you
give me he said I can't give you
anything and so what they did they say
I've got a solution oh yeah what's that
we'll take it out of the book of remove
it from the book of disorders of the
list of disorders okay that solves the
problem yeah and and again is it on the
rise that they do any scientific study
on this to find out at homosexuality
time to rise because if it's under eyes
it's not a chimeric problem and if it's
not a cosmetic problem then it is a
abnormal and it is very likely a mint
disorder right because it's not normal
you might say well bill mental disorder
you know one of the arguments though gay
lobby raises is that you know the sex is
is for pleasure if we're having fun at
cetera and it doesn't matter you choose
the partner you want for having fun well
I disagree with that I and not I don't
condemn them that's not the point the
point is that sex was invented by plants
see the plant scene existed before human
stated before animals did because you
can't have herbivores until you have
hurts so the herbs were there before and
I think the herbs also invented sex and
later on animals invented sex and as far
as I know you know plants don't throw
their little pollen to each other and I
say hey cutie you wanna play with pollen
today you know no no they don't they
don't enjoy it or maybe they enjoy sex I
don't know but it's for procreation
that's the only purpose of sex the fact
that we monkeys have turned it into
something pleasurable because we enjoy
it so much you know that's where we
distorted the purpose what Mother Nature
designed is the purpose for sex and of
course the homosexuals they can't
procreate between them so they have to
invent an excuse they say no sex is for
pleasure it's not for procreation and
yeah again my argument is that sex is
only for procreation if you have you
know fun with it as a as a secondary
effect you know more power to you but
that was not the primary purpose of sex
maybe the pleasure was there too so that
you would do it again say hey I like
that I'm gonna do it again but what was
the point the point is to get the female
pregnant in any species yeah okay
and so we have here a little bit of
militancy
on the part of all these people okay and
here's one guy started around 1961 a guy
you should him and his brother I think
they were both gay I think they had
their
or three brothers I think all three were
gay and it turns out that this guy
writes or I think either Oxford or
Cambridge University and he he suggests
what we should have today
okay so 61 we're 60 years further in
time this is what the guy proposes for
our society okay
his name is Geoffrey Kahuna Gor he
writes man to man the characteristic
feature of pederasty pederasty is that
there is an age differential between the
partners the older being the lover and
the younger the beloved typically the
Adela sand boy is chosen as he beloved
in an older man after the passage of
some years the young man marries and
produces children when his own children
are reared he becomes the lover of
adolescence this pattern is socially
viable this pattern is socially viable
by socially viable I mean that it can be
followed by all or most of the men of
the society without psychological
discomfort or the production of obvious
neuroses and without interfering with
the genital competence and fertility
necessary to maintain the population
okay so uh a lot of people take this and
say well yeah Alex the great he wasn't
so great and turns out that he was
homosexual and he said well maybe he was
bisexual and some people say then the
other people say well no really he
didn't like no females at all and a lot
of Greeks didn't like the women at all
what they did was say oh honey take off
your clothes I got to do sex again that
boring stuff you know with you because I
got a procreate you know and I got to do
it for the fatherland and then I'm going
with Joey you know and having sex with
him
this is there a notion they say that
either they they were because again he
comes from the mind of a homosexual and
so he does you can't he can't put it his
mind in ours like we can't put our minds
in his and so they say these things like
it's it's a fact you know it's it's my
experience that's what they'll say and
my experience is a little different so
don't introduce it as a fact okay this
is the this is where the problem comes
in and again because these are the
so homosexuals who are revising all
these things that's where you got to be
careful okay and here's a how these
people are proceeding today with this
militancy okay let's see if I can get it
up here and this is what the gay lobby
is up to this is how they in fact this
comes from with 19 and 1987 the recipe
for successful militancy gay militancy
right prescribed by early homosexual
theorists in the late 80s is talk about
gays and gayness as loud as possible and
as often as possible
a portray gays as victims not as
aggressive challengers this is the these
are the tactics the a strategy okay to
get homosexual introduced into the
population to like them right and this
is 1987 okay so what are we now thirty
years in the future give homosexual
protectors a just cause yeah make gays
look good make the victimizers look bad
you know the homophobes yeah and get
funds from corporate America so that was
their strategy and this the one they
followed and they continued in their
book after the ball right the imagery of
sex per se should be downplayed in the
issue of gay rights reduced as far as
possible to an abstract social question
yeah you should not focus on the sexual
act
you should talk about rights and
politics okay that's what they were
saying okay and here's a here's these
other two guys and I mean these are the
same guys sorry again the guy in the
left I think already died and says the
first order of business is
desensitization of the American public
concerning gays and gay rights to
desensitize the public is to help it
view homosexuality with indifference
instead of with Queen with with keen
emotion okay so this is this is what
their strategy was and it worked
they beat the Christian lobby Christian
Lobby was out there you know waving
their arms and making money and
recruiting people on these guys said huh
we're going to be smarter we're gonna
change the Psychiatric Association
classification of homosexuals as a
disorder is a mental disorder and we're
gonna do these things running a
corporate America to fund us and we're
gonna treat homosexuals that poor
suffering people and we're gonna treat
anyone who attacks him as a monster a
Nero okay so this one has happened and
they were extremely successful I have to
say you know okay so where am i coming
with all this well I'm saying that again
homosexuality is under eyes because they
have so much power and I think if you
let it go enough it'll destroy humanity
in other words it's a consequence that
because of homosexuality or or autism
but these two things are are symptoms
that something is wrong with humanity
and what is wrong is that we lost our
genetic diversity nothing we can do
anything about unless we sleep with
gorillas tomorrow and change our genetic
code a little bit you know enrich it so
to speak or maybe do it artificially if
that's even possible I mean what kind of
monster are you gonna create it right
and so there was a guy who John Calhoun
he's a psychologist and he was a also an
ecologist so he studied the influence of
ecology on psychology but he was
primarily a psychologist he ran a series
of tests over the years about I would
say he ran about 30 tests over a period
of 30 and he ran 25 tests over a period
of 30 years about 30 years from 1947 to
1919 75 something like that and he ran
in with ransom with mice and it's
important to for you to see what this
guy concludes because it's more or less
my point of view and a lot of people are
not aware of his work and so here I'm
making his work available to you and
here it goes okay oh shut my mouth Oh
dr. Calhoun wanted to find out what
would happen to a
Colony given everything mice need except
living space the result was chilling two
and a half years ago more than two
thousand mice were packed into Mouse
city today a tiny handful of survivors
Huddle's in one corner of the city
dr. Calhoun explains what the
overcrowding did to Mouse city's
inhabitants the last thousand animals
falling never learned to develop the
social behaviors they never learned to
be aggressive which is necessary in
defense of homesite they never learned
to tort there was no mating being no
mating there were no progeny and the
older animals whose behavior was already
becoming disrupted they eventually
reached an age too old to reproduce and
so it was all left up to these last
thousand or so we call the beautiful
ones because not engaging in any
stressful activity and only paying
attention to themselves they groomed
themselves well so they look very fine
specimen but from that point on which
was about the time that you were here
two and a half years ago his
reproduction totally ceased and the
animals have just aged and died
okay and here's a corollary to that okay
let's see if I can get this up there you
hang in there for a second hey perhaps
the most chilling conclusion from his
mouth City study says dr. Calhoun is
that once this change in social behavior
occurs it apparently cannot be reversed
this fact in fact
irreversible phase shifts that gets some
of us a particular concern over the fate
of the human situation because we've
seen worldwide the breaking down of
social role the increase in contact this
might lead to an overriding of our
control of our total culture would be
fed into a process which would either
fix us
rigidly forever into some sort of global
tribalism without any adaptation to
change or they would result that
eventually found declined very much like
we've seen here so now you see where I'm
coming from on this I'm saying that we
are like these rats and mice he did it
first with rats than with mice and one
thing you should keep in mind is that
calhoun was one of the first to create
homosexuality in the lab these mice at
the end in the rats as well became some
of them became homosexual and he talks
about in his report and the first group
that he put in there were four couples
and he were her sexual see he put four
couples for male for females each one
selected a female they went to their
nests they did their thing and several
generations later we find homosexuals in
that in that enclosure and one there are
many factors one is density right one is
that I don't think you factored then the
question is where
the mice in their historical graph on
genetic diversity I mean how much
diversity do mice have and where are
they in their history right the mice
that you use as a starting material also
with the gross a filler file that flies
that they use in labs we don't know
where they are in their genetic
diversity I mean have they been around
for millions of years a hundred thousand
years you know we don't know these
things but maybe a genetic analysis
would give us an idea and that would
also show us that we have a problem and
then the other problem again is the fact
that you have here founders effect
followed by maybe not bottlenecks
because there were no diseases in there
but you do have a founders affect all
these came from the same founders and so
you have you know mice at which after
several generations are in breeding and
and also has to be taken into
consideration so there's a lot of
factors to look at here but I guess what
he was saying essentially is that our
cities are like that enclosure there we
have all these mice we call men and in
cities voluntarily and we have cities of
20 million and 20 and 10 million
whatever these ant holes these enormous
and holes and there's the density and
then you have the two whammies there the
first one is that we have no genetic
diversity of 200,000 200,000 years of
inbreeding and on top of that you know
we usually marry someone in our own town
or someone we know from our own species
in general or race or whatever and what
happens is that you know after a while
you have children with problems like the
Amish are showing ours is a bigger
picture than the Amish Amish were only
they're only like three hundred
twenty-five thousand Amish in the United
States today
out of those fifteen hundred families
that are originally populated the states
in the case of humans were eight billion
but we come from the 1 billion that were
here on earth in 1820 and from a hundred
million maybe that were here
the beginning of the Christian era we
come from all those people and not from
Allah when we come from a segment of
that group which also went through these
periods of population bottlenecks
followed by founders effects and that
has streamlined our genetic code and
that makes us evermore perfect
we are immune to diseases on the one
hand for example we are maybe the best
specimens we are the beautiful ones from
that whole cycle right and this is where
it all ends so here's my closing
argument okay
and this is my population pyramid based
on that for Humanity okay so I think
we're very close to reaching the end
either either because we our population
pyramid overturns drastically and we
because in partly because we lose our
genetic diversity and we stop
procreating we have more homosexuals
more autistic people and more people
with mental and physical problems and
the other one is that hopefully that
doesn't happen because I think we're
gonna die in a different way we're gonna
succumb to a mass extinction which is an
ecological issue and that's got to do
with economics we're not going to
produce food because money is going to
disappear with that I'll see you next
time and hopefully we'll get back to
some celebrities of mathematical